love my wednesday chats with the co-host
of good morning football his
ten questions with kyle brandt podcast
drops on the ringer in spotify every
wednesday today's episode is with
matthew mcconaughey
our buddy kyle brandt back here on his
wednesday spot how are you sir
well rich i'm uh i'm full uh brockman
and del tufa overnighted me some chicago
style
you are welcome so generous of them
in appreciation of all the work that
i've put in this fall they wanted me to
make sure i was well fed and i thank you
guys thank you got it you got it you're
part of the team kyle you know
did you give something to k and
everybody else yeah absolutely i sent
them to
schrager will have five or six and then
nato peter two you can
eat half of the pizza and then kay is
all into it she's from chicago so it's
nice that the guys that you appreciate
sure send the pizzas to i i could not
thank you enough it was an early holiday
present sure you're welcome
you know kyle i appreciate that like
let's just say if michael davies uh was
around your set uh
every day let's just say that okay uh in
uh the
one of the top notch producers in the
entire business um
uh uh also uh the man who put you all
together for good morning football
what what what if uh uh you all got
together and decided to get some pizza
and didn't include him would you would
you do something like that when you knew
that he loved pizza would you do that
kyle it's just so inconceivable rich
that you you appreciate the people who
put you in those positions we not only
would there be pizza i think we would
have the uh the garlic knots
yeah maybe some wings uh pictures of
beer and then if it was michael davies
we we'd go out and we'd all play tennis
and work on our one-handed backhand
which is a master so it would be a great
experience as as workers and as the
godfather put us together absolutely
so that's all i'm saying and then and
then once once the
you know you did in fact um well
give that um maybe after forgetting
it it doesn't it doesn't wash it all
away kyle
right yeah and and in retrospect rich
maybe i have the facts wrong
it was only one or two pizzas right that
you missed out on no twelve no
oh twelve a whole dozen pizzas yeah
that's a lot of food
yeah yeah that's a lot of fun
uh yeah i don't know about you but
occasionally i'll make the terrible faux
pas as a husband
i actually made it just an hour ago
where i'll come home from errands or
work or whatever and i'll walk in the
house and i'll have a sandwich under my
arm
or a salad or something and my wife will
say
what's up where's mine and i just freeze
a deer in headlights because i didn't
for one second to get her one and it's
because i'm an inconsiderate jerk
sometime
but i would certainly never do it with
12 whole pizzas for someone that helps
you know put a roof over my head well i
i do have uh here uh a man in t.j
jefferson who lives by
himself uh a man in mike del tufo who is
divorced and
had an emmy thrown at him and broke into
many pieces by his ex-wife
and i have a man in chris brockman who's
just beginning to become a grown man
uh with with a baby and somebody you've
been living with sarah now two years
right
like two plus there you go so i mean
he's coming around he's coming around
they're not even like the dregs pizza
meaning like you know they send you 12
and two of them are the
the veggie that no one wants you guys
couldn't even given that
the pepperoni sausage i get it but it's
like the crappiest doughnuts in the box
that no one eats there must have been
some of that left over for rich
pizzas though i never thought though
it's just it never dawned on them
it never dawned on them okay
just you know i've got something planned
for
after your segment uh kyle so um
i'm looking for i mean literally the
next 34 minutes of this show are going
to be great because our conversations
are always fun and then the
the finish they have no idea what's
coming their way none of it okay
it's so relatable rich i mean that i
mean you could ask
you know you could ask darius miles
about the pizzagate and he'll have pigs
darius miles and quentin richardson
would definitely get pizzas for each
other they go back to their aau days
that's what happens you know i've known
brockman for about del two for longer
than brockman
i mean a long time i know so they're
more at fault than me because
no no no no okay so it's you know what
again let's put a pin in this because
we're going to hit this hard as they say
in the television business
uh towards the end of this hour uh all
right kyle
um the story of the nfl entering week 11
is what
i'll give you this i'm just going to be
excited
i don't think i've said that i don't
know since i was in college i'm
really i think this is i think this is
the biggest raiders game in about three
or four years
i i really do back that 2016 they had a
great season and car was good and they
had a thursday night or at the end of
the year i think it might have been week
14
and they played the the chiefs and they
just got crushed and it was alex smith
and spencer ware
and they i feel like have not been heard
from since this is a big deal
if they sweep mahomes i mean you go two
for two
it just it validates gruden it validates
mayok it validates car
it is it is not an oakland raiders
moment it's a las vegas
raiders moment and it would be complete
shock and awe i don't even care if they
go to the wild card and lose the raiders
2020 was the year they swept mahomes and
make him bleed twice
and you know rich we got we got bus gate
from victory lap after the game i'm way
way into that i like that
even andy reid was a little chippy about
the raiders taking a victory lap around
arrowhead stadium and gruden was next
questioning people i mean this is really
really good stuff
and i have a i have a prediction not a
game prediction but i have a feeling
that
uh when and if tyree kill scores a
touchdown in las vegas this weekend i
think he and his fellow wide receivers
are going to do a
team bus celebration in which they do
laps around the end zone
there's heat on this game and it's so
fun to talk about i agree with you man
i agree with you and i've already called
my shot barring any covet or
injury-related
uh uh issues between now and then i'll
call my shot and say the raiders are
going to take it
and i love it i did i i called my shot
and you know
if i'm wrong i'm wrong and i still think
the chiefs are are the best team in the
afc right now
but um you do throw records out these
are the games in which
you know amari cooper you know catches
200 yards even though
he doesn't catch any yards against
anybody else which is what was happening
before he became a dallas cowboy i mean
i've seen them in person
um you know i i've seen games where the
raiders uh
did in fact i believe if if i'm not
mistaken
um they did win a thursday night
football game when they were winless
against the kansas city chiefs who came
in i've seen these things in person
so i i know you can throw records out
but to me
to me sunday night has the possibility
of a
of a of a crowning in a way of the
running back in this league who nobody
really talks about
and it's josh jacobs i think jacobs
arrives with intent
i think he when i first saw him start
running uh and i gingerly mentioned this
to mayok because whenever i
evaluate and do comps mike always gives
me that evil eye because that's not my
lane
um but to me he looks like zeke he's got
zeke ability he's big he's strong
he gets stronger in the fourth quarter
he wants it in the fourth quarter
and um and he's also the way that carr
doesn't wing it around 40 times
um i'm i'm looking to see him on sunday
night that's what i'm looking to see
i am too it's the running back position
is my favorite one and josh jacobs is
fantastic if anybody
wants to look at him and want to see
what he's all about and pull up the tape
it's a couple weeks ago and it's raiders
browns it's at cleveland it's a one
o'clock kickoff it's totally off the
radar no one watched this game because
it was
really low scoring 16 to six the raiders
the
the raiders win uh josh jacobs was over
30 carries
which is something of an anachronism you
don't see that anymore and they just
decide it's windy as hell we're not
going to throw it and i don't think they
can stop
jacobs and to your point it's everything
that you want from the combine from the
game tape it's it's the shoulder is
lowered it's finishing runs he doesn't
run out of bounds
he's mean he's good and when we start
saying well let's look at the top
running backs and lead khmer is amazing
derek henry is amazing you know
christian mccaffrey's kind of hurt
like josh jacobs is nowhere in that
conversation if they beat the chiefs
with him with the chiefs coming off a
buy
josh jacobs is a superstar and i feel
like john gruden is the face of this
year i'm so excited for it
kyle brandt here on the rich eisen show
drew brees is going to be out for
i mean look i know her hearing two three
weeks he's a 41 year old man with a
partially punctured lung and and bruised
ribs um
it's it's jameis's time here i know
taysom hill there could be some run for
him here how do you think this affects
the nfc moving forward well first i'll
relate to drew uh drew brees and i are
the exact same age almost to the day i
think he's like six days older than me
okay
um two years ago rich i was skiing i was
clumsy
i took a really bad wipeout and uh
i cracked two ribs i had to be the guy
who was you know i skied down on one ski
it was a massive crack two ribs
and if anybody listening has never
broken ribs i hadn't had any kind of
issue you think ah it's ribs you got 24
of them what's the big deal
it's unbelievably paralyzing to the
point that when you have cracked ribs
if you sneeze that is a real problem
because you can exacerbate
the injury you can be in crazy pain the
doctors give you
a a res uh kind of like a routine to go
through if you're going to sneeze we
have to get down
hug your ribs and hold your breath it's
just sneezing
i'm not talking about getting hit or
throwing touchdowns so i sympathize
completely
for drew brees and i think it is going
to be a while considering he also has to
puncture long and everything so
i don't think he's going to be back soon
in my opinion now
we get to ride on the james express and
i got to tell you i am so excited rich i
know you were there calling that game
the bucks texas last year in tampa
and it was all this talk about i don't
know can james figure it out can he look
we never know we're going to get first
play you remember what happened
pick six jameis winston i got called
back dude
do a penalty i i just i think the danger
here is that i've seen a lot of
comparisons to teddy bridgewater
going uh undefeated last year and then
coming into relief duty
teddy bridgewater is nothing like jameis
winston jameis swenson is a chuckler
he is dollar store brett favre be damned
he's going to throw it and throw it and
throw it and i don't buy any story line
that says well he's calmed down and he's
changed his stripes now he's in the drew
brees
he's a chucker and i i think this is
going to be fantastic theater over the
next month well i mean here's the
theater kyle i already said because i
like
you know like the nfl is a narrative
generating a machine i've seen tons of
narratives
and i can see them coming from a mile
away i can already
see a successful jameis winston
yep calling into question drew brees's
arm strength again
that low this is what it looks like when
you can throw it 50
60 yards downfield like that that is
coming
that is coming i could i could i could i
don't know
monday morning but i'm just i don't know
but i'm
seeing it coming you know and then and
then
because teddy bridgewater last year it
was definitely not a question of
okay it's drew's team right this time
around now it's 41 years old and we did
have four weeks of of wondering whether
he had the arm strength and
he came on our show uh a couple of weeks
last week
actually one week ago yesterday and
bristled like people
who say that you know don't know the
defenses are in front of me and he's
right when he says that i'm not saying
that this is a correct
narrative that's coming down the pike
but you can i mean i
we could make bets on which show and
which broadcaster
will be the first in on this uh you
could we if there's a place
in the town where you think sunday night
football will be lit
that there is a place to place a bet on
it uh i i would i would venture to say
who would be the favorite in the top two
right now yeah for this um
that that should be the draft about who
in the media
who's your first round pick who's going
to say hey look out
drew brees maybe he should stay on that
sideline because i got to be honest the
game hasn't even happened yet
i heard something this morning that was
to the effect of
now sean payton will be unshackled
now sean payton can really coach him
since he wants he can do taste some he
can do james that's the precursor
sean payton has been weighted down i've
heard it already that's the precursor
yes those are markers it's the precursor
this is amazing
it's a precursor it's coming oh my gosh
it's
it's exotic as hell it's already gonna
happen and uh
listen um james and taysom could be
pretty cool
i i just don't think everybody's saying
that
jameis is going to change i can't get
over it the only change
and and i know this sounds like a smokey
take but i fully believe in it
we have seen for years going back to
tallahassee
the memes and the jokes about jameis and
the squinting and the vision
and the limited vision this gentleman in
the offseason had lasik surgery and came
out saying
i can see license plates now i can reach
three cents i've never done that before
that's a pretty big deal for a
quarterback yes anybody out there
listening has lasik it's a game changer
and if that really helps him see better
maybe we do see a new one i believe in
the power of lasik i think for the uh
saints to have a super bowl in 2020 uh
that may also need to be james's vision
i see live people that's what he's
basically saying hayley joel
winston yes haley joel winston use that
on good morning football go for it
uh before i let you go mcconaughey for
uh this week dynamite right
dynamite how to be great he shows up
exactly like you want
he's got literally has a glass of wild
turkey he's leaned back he's got long
hair
and he plays the hits he's going to talk
all about how he got the role and the
time to kill how he got
dazed to confuse he has a passionate
take
that he refuses to wear deodorant and he
will make you believe it is the right
move to do
uh unbelievable takes on the
reconnaissance and how we went from
rom-coms to true detective and dallas
buyer's club just
awesome we played bongos we literally
played bongos and drank whiskey it was
the most fun i've ever had in my life
that's again that's dropping today on uh
on ringer and spotify every single
wednesday
uh by the way i was just uh going back
in my brain just to bring this full
circle
um it was an owen 10 raiders team that
beat
a seven and uh a six and four uh seven
and three
chiefs team in 2014. that was the birth
of latavius murray for the
oh yeah for the raiders now with new
orleans he ran for damn near 200 yards
against him
uh when he was on the raiders it happens
the raiders and chiefs of crazy things
happen
for the writers and chiefs this is a
great one richard i'm with you too
thanks for the call
kyle get some pizza please oh i got it
today
and they think that that that it would
stop the train that's about to come but
it's not oh that train's taken off
i know you have a special guest coming
up i cannot wait i'll be listening
thanks kyle appreciate it that's
kyle brent good morning football every
single day at seven eastern time he had
blake shelton on yesterday you know
blake's a die hard
cardinals and he loves good morning
football it's great it's just great to
see a tent pole show on nfl network
every single day
every single morning